Bon voila maintenant je peux vous le dire, j'ai acheté une cafetière, pas parce que j'aime bien le café
non pas dutout, c'est pour me la péter en fait, aujourd'hui les gens qu'en ils pensent au café c'est.........
alors qu'en vrai c'est................
what else?
"c'est pas bientôt fini ce boucan" (voix du voisin )
non c'est ingénieux d'avoir mis un marteau piqueur dans une cafetière bonne idée, hein très intelligent
en plus j'étais obligé de m'acheter une cafetière, obligé pour avoir la classe, tu ne peux pas avoir la classe
avec du café soluble par exemple, pas possible
-Je te fais un Café ?                                                                          - Oui s'il te plait
- Mets de l'eau chaude, tu te démerdes
CONNARD
Non, non non
Pour avoir la classe il faut absolument la cafetière avec les capsules, il y a une vingtaine de capsule
de toutes les couleurs, des noms que tu ne retiens pas, Livento
enfin c'est une capsule marron, et qui on plus ou moins toutes le même gout
à un moment il faut se le dire, il suffit de lire la description du contenu des capsules
qu'on se fout totalement de ta gueule
Vivalto lungo, complexe et équilibré
et ma capsule préféré dulsao do brasil, doux et moelleux
un café moelleux???
on vous prend pour des cons et ça vous va, hein un café moelleux
pas de problème, OK, café moelleux c'est parti, qui veut un café moelleux?
tu veux un café moelleux, café moelleux pour tout le monde
alors la technique pour paraitre connaisseur en café c'est de faire semblant en fait
tu fais genre, hhhuuuuummmmm, je le reconnais il est complexe et tout
le problème c'est que ça ne dure pas très longtemps en règle générale
- tiens ton dulsao do brasil
-merci
-hum doux et moelleux, enfin vraiment comme je l'aime
- en fait je t'ai fait un vivalto lungo
- oui.... oui, oui on reconnait autant pour moi c'est le coté complexe en fait
- non je déconne c'est bien un dulsao do brasil
- voila c'est ce que j'avais dis au début
- non en fait c'est du coca
- ah oui il y a des bulles
alors le petit truc a savoir pour faire le connaisseur en café ça va être toujours c'est extremement simple
-tiens ton café
-merci
-combien de sucre ?
Le mec qui s'y connait en café vraiment, le boit sans sucre
- ah non non, moi je le bois sans sucre en fait
(voix off) c'est amer, c'est dégeux, c'est amer, je vais vomir, il me faut du sucre , c'est amer, c'est dégueulase
-c'est tellement bon
(voix off) c'est amer, c'est dégeux
retrouvez toutes mes autres vidéos sur cyprien.fr d'ailleurs vous pouvez partager ma video sur Facebook
si vous voulez et si tu rejoins ma page je t'offres un café, je suis comme ça
pas mal.......
c'est amer
dégueulase